The important thing inheritance provides is a way to use attributes defined in
the Base class in the derived class without needing to cut and paste any code.
Let's try a simple example to see how this works before getting back to our
Dishes. I hope no one's too hungry. Don't worry. Fried Python is a dish best
served cold. Let's start by supposing we have a Bear class. Which has a
GrizzlyBear as a subtype. Here's the Bear. Don't be put off by its color and
peace symbol. Looks like a peaceful bear. It's actually very violent. And it's
got an eat method. It can eat a Human. Let's look at how that looks like in
code. Here's what that looks like in code. We've defined a Bear class, we've
defined a GrizzlyBear with Bear as its base class. We don't actually have any
code in GrizzlyBear . In the bear class we've defined attributes. We got an
initializer that sets the name of the bear and we've got an eat method that eats
a victim. A victim has a name. We'll assume the victim is a Human. So let's see
how that works. I'm going to import from the bear class, the bear, GrizzlyBear,
and Human definitions. I haven't shown you Human, but you should be able to
guess what it is. We need to give the Bear someone to eat. And we'll create some
instances of those objects, a Human instance and we'll create a Bear instance.
Since Bear has an eat method, the Bear should be able to eat a victim, and
indeed it can. We can also create a GrizzlyBear. We didn't define any attributes
for GrizzlyBear, but it has some. The GrizzlyBear can also eat Dave. It's okay,
Dave can be used more than once. And we can look a little more closely at what
these attributes are, so it says that the bound method of the GrizzlyBear object
and the GrizzlyBear object is this one, the Bear object, also has an eat method
and it's of the Bear object. Now, this is an attribute, so we can assign it.
Let's get rid of the eat method for Bear, because our Bear is a nice peaceful
bear. Did that change the eat method for the Grizzly? And it didn't. The eat
method for Grizzly is still there, that method got bound when the GrizzlyBear
instance was created and the GrizzlyBear can still eat Dave as many time as he
wants.